this is the first dinner together we've
had as a family a long time let's try to
survive it yeah first let's say grace
Jackie would you like to take a knee I
should have tried to understand why you
voted the crazy way that you did and I
should have understood that you know you
want the government to give everybody
free healthcare cuz you're a
good-hearted person who can't do simple
math at the top of the show the Roseanne
reboot generated an enormous rating 18
million Americans watched the show last
night
funny what can happen when Hollywood
makes programming that's not
condescending toward half the country
joining us now to analyze this in our
seen and unseen segment is Fox News
contributor author of the book will
wilder the law staff of Wonders and
paperback next week
Raymond Arroyo go out and get will
wilder all right fantastic what's going
on Roseanne today's just massive we
predicted it was gonna be immediate ng
this thing exploded and it exploded
because it's a safe fun place for people
to have a political discussion but I
would caution people Roseanne is not a
traditional constrain I know she voted
for Trump the character voted for Trump
but if you peer beyond that this is a
complicated family they're dealing with
a surrogacy a daughter wants to engage
in surrogacy you've got a grandson who's
kind of cross-dressing they're dealing
with a lot of subplots here this is not
straight down the middle conservatism
but that's what made it work it's not
predictable it's not a polemic but I
will tell you look where it resonated
Laura Tulsa Oklahoma Cincinnati Ohio 29%
of Kansas City Missouri 29% of that city
but that matter Kansas this years ago I
guess not much it hit middle America it
resonated with me because middle America
as I said in the angle feels turned off
and tuned out to what's happening in the
popular culture it doesn't reflect who
they are no and this does these are
working-class people trying to make ends
meet and problems are hitting them and
the American Dream isn't playing out the
way it's supposed to but let me tell you
just to give you a sense of context 18
million people watch this one will
grace premiered 10 million people
watched it it's down to 4 million a week
oh and it went at the reboot of will
engrave the will were to reboot Overland
Grace more of a liberal at faith what
people saw this than the stormy Daniels
interview and it's the highest demo 18
to 49s me a little bit of sushi reminds
me a little bit of what happened when
duck dynasty came on in A&E because they
were sitting at the table praying they
cared about each other they fought but
it was about traditional it reminds me a
little bit of that whether it's Roseanne
or Blue Bloods that sense of this is
real this is authentic Americans want
that is below blogs I don't know that
was a Tom Selleck show about this I love
that family okay sweet Jesus ice cream
in Toronto what on earth is this well a
lot of religious groups are up in arms
including Bill Donohue with the Catholic
League a lot of evangelical groups they
want to boycott this this is a Canadian
firm that is reaching out now into
Baltimore and and Minnesota this is one
of their ads it looks like the little
girl is a cannibal but look at the look
at the logo sweet Jesus up top yeah in
most of the logo the sweet has an
upside-down cross as the T and that
little that little and you see that
lovely Lightning sign that some say is a
demonic sign referencing when Lucifer
fell from heaven like a lightning bolt
and so the ice cream I haven't tasted it
and after watching these ads I'm not
sure I want to my question there really
creepy ads and many of them
anti-christian they take biblical verses
turn them on their ears things like love
is patient love is kind but you can't
lick it above a chalice this you can get
away it's always during Holy Week it's
always very you can get away with trying
to intimidate and silence Christians
insult them intimidate talk show hosts
because we have a certain point of view
some of us the the effort to silence or
domain those with whom you disagree it's
just well the owners of ridiculous a
week oh sweet Jesus because that was the
explosion explosive reaction people had
when they tasted it imagine if your
reaction was lovely holy Mohammed oh
yeah that would work would you be able
to put that in the mall
of America all right quickly I got the
last Susan Rice and the Obamas are going
to Netflix yeah that's going on well
Susan Rice is the first person I think
of as it was an entertainment board
right
what's her what's her experience oh I
although her her interviews on all those
sunday shows when she said that video
caused the Benghazi that wasn't there
waiting and the Obamas are now going to
Netflix it appears Barack Obama is going
to be doing it looks like a talk show
about issues and Michelle Obama may be
doing a Let's Move type show that you
might be good she's in great shape so so
a lot of people are saying no to Netflix
as a result I saw that trending today
see the drop Netflix as a hashtag I just
don't like a lot of the shows on that
yeah I don't like the politicization of
any of now it's entertainment should be
neutral common ground that's what made
the Roseanne Barr thing stick I think
that's what people want well it will it
hold next week it won't be that high oh
yeah but it'll hold
I think it'll hold Roseanne had a huge
following before like the middle like
Everybody Loves Raymond there's a
built-in audience and if they stay true
to the characters which they have so far
which is unpredictable and outside of
the political you know what I want to
hear Norman Lear who's still alive I'd
like to hear what he has to say
well beerschot one day at a time was
just renewed third season on Netflix
with Rita Moreno so look all these shows
have everything that is old is new again
fresh out of ideas Raymond Arroyo
everyone go out and get will wild
they're awesome awesome paperback my
kids well read it